Thank You command J thank you for having
me nice to have you on the program you
know I never say this I don't use a lot
of showbiz lingo because technically I'm
not in show business but everybody is
talking about you in this movie - Oh Dee
you've got what they call in Hollywood
heat right now there's a there's a buzz
well I think they're talking about my
butt crack I I showed some butt crack in
the movie and I noticed there's a lot of
butt crack in the show tonight
so maybe you're trying to steal some of
my heat get my cracking shirt that's so
sad if we're like trying to steal your
butt crack Heat
but that's what we're trying to do sure
you know let me ask him I was talking to
before the show you mentioned you're a
basketball fan yeah I'm a huge well it
just doesn't seem like we can lose the
Lakers are just unstoppable
and another thing is close to Iran yeah
it would be then it would be awesome if
we had Knicks Lakers finals cuz we would
kick your no seriously
flex it's because you guys have a great
coach but you don't have to feel Jackson
baby with the ancient mind control where
they lose your coach when he got when he
was separating the guys in the fight
because he had cojones to get in between
those dudes
yeah and his hair looked real cool and
yeah did did I'm winded from that whoo
escapade I just went through just try
and relax okay I worry about you I don't
want to need to happen to ya that's good
that's good thank you so you're in town
with Tenacious D yes you guys are having
a good time in the Big Apple you
enjoying the city well I was but then
now I'm a little freaked out I lost my
wallet yesterday I'd left it on the cab
and as soon as I got out of the cab no
no wait wait
wave and freaking the guys driving not
up two blocks I was running and then I
called my mom and an emergency I always
called my mom and I was like what do I
do she said two things cancel the credit
cards but now that you're a celebrity
you have to you have to go and file a
report with the police because they can
not only steal my money they can steal
my actual identity and take my ID and go
to like Prada and say I'm Jack Black
just give me some shoes and some what is
your mom talking about she's okay she
was saying someone could be asleep oh
and my girlfriend he's someone could be
doing my movies right yeah she's
now what do you make 8 weird faces a
second I've noticed about yeah it's just
a little nervous chick I've never done
one of these things before mean hit TV
show exactly something's been bothering
me a little bit on your mind what's
brought well the word on the street is
that andis bailing on the show is that
true he's taking off because if he is
the thing is upgrade time upgrade time
check it out
are you pitching yourself I made a video
replacement yes I am yes you made an
audition tape yeah you've gone to a lot
of trouble haven't you I gave it to the
dudes in the back and if we don't have
any dudes in the back so we have some
highly skilled technical team there are
fired all the dudes but with their pimp
caps I just want you to I just want you
to get a little taste of what I could
offer no offense hey none taken
I think you got some chops right take
you to school
all right let's what's it that maybe
you're gonna bring Phil Jackson in here
did I bring the West Coast the whole
thing what's that let's see I want to
see the Jack Black sidekick audition
tape can we roll this please
okay here's me listen and notice how
interested I am really right no way
continue come again
I'm getting this down slow down slow
down right right now watch what happens
when the guest makes a wisecrack now
watch what I do when tonin tops the
guests wise Apple oh you're even funnier
than the guy
I can laugh so far that I get a
nosebleed now watch what happens when
the guest tells a sad story now watch
how I respond when a guest insults you
Conan hold up would you just say about
Conan
no he's at all what he's a skinny
beanpole freak what about no you finish
your insult mr. days of our lives that's
it come on Rosie ring-around-the-rosy
and all the payback I'd want Conan is
just an occasional spotlight too remote
on the side head I'm the go-to guy
watching the back of my buttock gone and
making sure that it's all good cuz I'm
the sidekick at the end of the couch
when you kick me I say out when you kick
me ah
[Music]
pretty good taste of what's coming huh
that's the tip of the iceberg all right
well you know whatever are so cool to
have you here really funny stuff jack
we'll take a break folks when we come
back Elliott Smith will be here check
back everybody
[Applause]
sidekick at the end of the couch